in case you needed a reminder that normal houses look lived in
and good moms are messy this is it
as much as I try to do it all
I just can't I can't homeschool
cook nutritious meals keep the house clean
and do all of the laundry all the time
so my house looks lived in 24 seven
because three out of the four of us are here pretty much all the time
and even though I'm a stay at home mom and don't work outside the house
my husband has zero expectation of me doing this all on my own
there are some days that he comes home to a clean house and a home cooked meal
but there are more days that he comes home to a complete disaster
whether the disaster is the house or me
he never knows I like to keep him on his toes
but today
I used the four hours of free time I had while the kids were at farm school
to deep clean our master bedroom
I need at least one space in my house completely clean
because it's off limits to the kids until after Christmas
it might actually stay clean